so I saw this article with this headline
I didn't even read the article because I
really don't need to because this is
something that's just extremely obvious
to me we have to get comfortable with
losing and rejection modern parenting
has demonized it eighth place trophies
trying to escape it fighting our battles
for our kids running to school and
arguing with teachers like fighting
other parents other kids modern
parenting has eliminated this whereas
parenting of many generations ago just
let the kids go outside and we all
naturally got used to rejection we got
into fights we got into arguments we
lost games things happened we seriously
need to stop over protecting our kids
our especially our 20 and 30 year olds
the coddling it's hurting them it's
killing their self-esteem put your
friends your family and most of all your
kids in positions to lose micro losing
leads to macro winning